can you comment about the difficulty of
the security from the Israel perspective
when there is a large number of people
that want to destroy it
how does Israel exist peacefully
this one state solution I don't know by
not shooting uh you know a journalist
doing her job and there's a new refugee
camp but that's not killing a 14 year
old standing on his front yard this
whole talk about you know
security and security fence and the
whole like propaganda of the Israeli
Defense Forces and this whole Iron Wall
ideology in which somehow they are
always defending themselves even though
they're you know Netanyahu and the
Israeli government
continue to talk about an existential
threat
about Iran being an existential threat
even though the Israeli government
is the only body that holds nuclear
weapons
in the region
they're the most sophisticated Army in
the region and yet they continue hiding
behind their fingers and talking about
an existential threat and talking about
how like they're insecure and and so on
and so forth I came here on the bus you
know I
I I live in a I live in a in a house
where everybody in the world can easily
Google it and get its address and
anybody can just walk into my house and
this is just and I'm lucky and
privileged as a Palestinian journalist
there are many Palestinian journalists
who lose their lives this is like that's
real insecurity but we don't even have
time to whine about it because there's
real [__] going on on the ground that we
are preoccupied within reporting on all
the time that we don't even have the
time to talk about how limited is our
institutional backing how limited is our
you know uh cyber security how limited
is our you know even Healthcare you know
like all of these things we don't even
have time to complain about but they're
the real life things that formulate an
insecure population
um that Israelis the Israel certainly
um does not suffer from
there's a tension here it's it's true
that the ideas of existential threats to
a nation have been used to expand the
military-industrial complex and
to uh to limit the rights of its people
so in the United States after 9 11
Iraq and Afghanistan were invaded under
some justification of their being Terror
in the world these big ideas
and in the same way yes Israel with the
existential threat of Iran is used to
expand its military might over the
region and control over the region but
it also has some truth to it in terms of
the
the threat that Israel is facing
including from Iran if Iran were to get
a nuclear weapon do you think there's a
threat from that but who has the nukes
right now
yeah but like we're talking about this
like Far Away monster that's like we're
we're scared of you know it's like
fear-mongering what do you mean any who
has the nukes some of it is
fear-mongering but uh some of it is true
I don't think it's true I don't think
it's true I think Israelis are obsessed
with genocide because they have enacted
genocide against us even when we talk
about like a future a liberation of
Palestine when we're talking about uh
anything they constantly jump to the
just saying things like oh they want to
throw us into the sea they want to kill
all Jews what kind of hyperbolic
[__] is that to say that if I am
chanting and Marching for my home not to
be taken away from me by some kind of
settler Court I am somehow demanding the
the murder of all Jews across the world
that is hyperbolic and the fact that we
cuddle cuddle it is insane to me so no I
don't think as things stand right now
um as the power of balance stands right
now I don't think there's an existential
threat to Israel and also let's redefine
what existential threat do we think
Israel
um
the Israeli regime the Zionist regime
should continue to exist in its forms
subjugating people and acting the crime
of apartheid according to a bazillion uh
human rights organizations do we think
that it should continue keeping people
on the cage if that's what people are
fighting to save then that says a lot
about the people who are feeling this
existential threat not me
do your beliefs represent
the Palestinian people meaning
how many people are there that want
Israel to be gone but what does it mean
for Israel to be gone uh what it means
is
for people who think of Israel as an
occupier who stole land that needs to go
away that this should be all Palestine
yeah but is that a bad thing for these
borders to be like for for the
occupation to end for these uh for the
land to be given back is that a bad
thing well there's different definitions
of occupation I there's still there's
people in their homes now right but is
it their home I'm not talking about like
I'm not talking about like some random
some random home
um but there are many many many many
many many many many many many many many
many many many many many Israelis
who drink their coffee every morning
from living rooms that are not theirs
that are not theirs there was there were
taken just a few decades ago yeah where
like the owners the rightful owners of
these homes are still lingering in
refugee camps
are still dreaming of return
there are homes on the land of Israel
that you wouldn't classify as stolen
I mean there is
like if it wasn't stole if it was built
but is the land stolen right is the but
all of this again I I try not to like
fall into this because it just like it
it feels so abstract and far away and
and this is not how Liberation is gonna
look like whatsoever and I'm not like
I'm not fixated on ethnic cleansing that
is not I'm not obsessed with ethnic
cleansing I'm obsessed with ending the
ethnic cleansing campaign that has been
that has been visited upon me and my
family and my community for seven plus
decades that's what I'm obsessed with uh
all of this other stuff about what
happens to the settlers and like uh you
know we want to kill all Jews and all of
this I think it's [__] and I think
it's ridiculous and I think you know
um fixating on it is like distracting
from the focal point
um
there needs to be an end to all of the
injustices to all of the atrocities you
know a little boy from Jerusalem should
be able to go jog around the city
without fearing getting shot that's like
the simplest thing we're asking for here
and we want our land back
and those things do not mean actually at
all the ethnic cleansing of another
people
well but that we should be precise here
so a little boy being able to run around
Jerusalem that's a great vision not just
safely but without
racism yeah without hate
that's a beautiful Vision yes but
people in West Jerusalem
people in Tel Aviv that have homes
do should they stay there if you have
the right to stay there don't it's like
maybe number 99 on my priorities list
I'm concerned with the refugees I'm
concerned with the teenagers and the in
the prisons I am concerned with my house
I'm concerned with my family's house in
Haifa I'm concerned there's a lot for me
to do before I can even tend
to the needs of my occupier yeah that is
the least of my concerns so you want the
low hanging fruit the obvious Injustice
is to end yeah
but still the long-term vision
of existential survival of a of Israel
which is the concern of its government
as concern of its people do you see a
future where Israelis
have a home in the region sure just not
in my front yard you know which where's
the front yard
there's literally there are literally
Jewish settlers yes one of which from
Long Island in my literal front yard yes
and this is the case in hundreds if not
thousands of Palestinian homes you know
no one is saying uh uh Jewish people
shouldn't exist or they shouldn't have
uh a state of their own if they I mean I
think all of all like all all religious
based states are like a bad idea all
nation states are about idea but
whatever if that's what they want to do
that's what they want to do but that
doesn't mean that they are allowed or
have a right to create and Implement a
system of Jewish Supremacy at my expense
that's not a crazy thing to say that is
not a controversial thing to say you can
have your state just don't kill anyone
thank you have a good day you know like
that's that's not a crazy thought to
have and uh seek and establish a
symmetry of power in the courts which is
the current source of Injustice
I mean that's when it comes to like
force expulsions in our home but there's
other there's immediate a myriad of
other ways
to the military the military I mean the
police
um if you look at like how many times I
should have brought the data with me but
if you look at how little times the
Israeli military or police has and like
investigated
its own people are indicted its own
people I mean just recently
um the killer
um who has been hailed a hero by some
some of Israeli Society who killed a
Palestinian man who is autistic who
lives inside the occupied old city where
again Israeli military has no business
being there or jurisdiction whatsoever
he was shot and killed by an Israeli
soldier who was trigger happy because
again they again they have this like
um Siege mentality where like any moving
object is going to kill them
um and he was shot and killed and
despite it being in broad daylight
despite being well documented despite
the victim being you know disabled
despite all of this he was acquitted by
the Israeli Court the military the
courts the government they all work
together which is why it's so ironic to
me that there are hundreds of thousands
of people marching on the streets of Tel
Aviv uh you know trying to save the
progressive Beacon that is the Israeli
Supreme Court when you'll find its
fingerprints all over the injustices
perpetuated against Palestinians be it
you know
legalizing and upholding the withholding
of slain Palestinian bodies who were
killed by the Israeli military to be
used as bargaining trips with Israeli
militaries be it making decisions to
dispossess entire Villages like
be it never once uh you know granting
release to any Palestinian who was held
in administrative detention without
charge or trial be it upholding the
legality of the family reunification law
that does not allow Palestinian couples
who hold different legal statuses of
reuniting and living together as
families I mean those are just some of
the few things I can think of about the
Israeli Supreme Court so they're like
the real the the real tension that
exists is
the lack of diversity on the Israeli
political spectrum that makes
um the vision for a future so limited
because those on what seems to be like
the the far left
um are defending and are defending an
extremely conservative
um institution that is a supreme court
that they record as Progressive when in
fact it is the opposite
uh of such so what what do we do how can
we how can we talk how can we have peace
with with people who
who are chanting to save you know the
very body that is displacing us you know
it's it's ridiculous